you can't become the number one drama on
television without generating at least
a little drama off-screen ncis has had
a long time to create those stories the
show first premiered all the way back in
2003.
here are the facts every ncis fan should
know about the cbs series
considering ncis is about the us
military you wouldn't expect the show to
be a big hit overseas
but since 2013 no fewer than eight
ncis movies have been shown on british
television
if you're wondering why you've never
heard of ncis movies before don't worry
you haven't actually missed anything
films like ncis judgment day and ncis
war
on terror were cobbled together by
assembling multi-episode arcs from the
tv shows into one continuous story
binge watching the old-fashioned way
ncis is objectively one of the most
popular shows on tv right now
if not of all time and as a spin-off of
jag
it's one of the few spin-offs to outlive
its predecessor
where most show's popularity drops off
over time that's just not true for ncis
in its seventh season it became the most
watched scripted show on broadcast
television
in its tenth it surpassed the only two
shows in front of it
sunday night football and american idol
to become the number one show on network
tv
it's never left the top three since but
as much as viewers love it
it hasn't won very many awards the show
has been nominated for more than a dozen
people's choice awards and three emmy
awards
twice for stunt performers and once for
outstanding guest actor in a drama
series
it did not win any of them law and order
has the famous sound used to transition
between scenes
these are their stories
ncis uses a similar sound effect
[Music]
that sound was made by ncis creator
donald belisario personally
when the show was entering production he
knew he wanted some kind of noise to
guide the viewer from scene to scene but
he wasn't sure what so he went into a
recording studio and started messing
around with a microphone
the one that ended up getting used is
just belisario tapping on a mic
with the palm of his hand koti de pablo
left the show
in season 11 which also ended the arc of
the relationship between her character
ziva
and tony denozzo that left michael
weatherly who played dinosaur with a lot
less to do
he realized that while the show was very
good to him it was time for him to move
on
weatherly went on to helm the
documentary jamaica man started his
own production company and landed a
starring role on bull
actress sasha alexander who moved on to
rizzoli and isles and a recurring role
on shameless was part of the original
cast of ncis when it hit the air in 2003
acting in a single camera tv drama
involves a lot of hard work and a lot of
long hours and by the end of the second
season
alexander was tired of the grind of
portraying special agent kate todd
as then show runner donald belisario was
writing the second season finale
alexander came to him in tears and
asked to be let go belisario complied
spoke on her behalf to persuade cbs
executives to let her
out of her contract and then killed off
her character alexander has since said
she doesn't regret leaving but wishes it
had gotten more press coverage during
her tenure
ncis has always been an ensemble show
but there's no mistaking that the star
is mark harmon
and for good reason he's a commanding
presence even with a character who's a
man of few words
leroy jethro gibbs doesn't talk any more
than he has to
and harmon can convey more with a glance
or a nod
than some actors manage with a monologue
in fact it's hard for writers especially
new ones to figure out how to write
dialogue for the character
sometimes before a script is finalized
writers will do what's called a
gibbs pass to determine what if any
dialogue can be edited down or removed
completely
the show's quirky slash genius forensic
scientist abby schutto gets a lot of
work done thanks in part to a steady
stream of a potent caffeine-rich energy
drink called calf pal
it's now a real commercially available
beverage but it's not what
actress paulie perette chugs when she's
portraying abby
the red stuff she's actually drinking is
tart and bitter unsweetened cranberry
[Music]
[Applause]
juice
paulie parrett who plays abby on ncis is
extremely well qualified to play a
forensic scientist
a couple of decades ago she considered
becoming an fbi agent and she has a
master's degree in criminal science from
valdosta state university
in georgia she was even admitted into
the john jay school of criminal science
in new york
she worked several jobs to pay her way
through including as a cook on a boat
somebody who worked in the co-check room
told her about a director who was
looking for commercial actors
and paulie peret gave it a shot earning
roles in advertisements as well as guest
spots on tv shows before eventually
landing on ncis
one of the perks of holding a high rank
in the real life naval criminal
investigative service or
the u.s navy is the possibility of a
cameo on ncis
in 2005 around the time that he retired
from the post he'd held for eight years
real world ncis director david brandt
guest starred on an episode as
ncis special agent david brandt his
successor as director thomas vitro
also appeared on the series making a
brief appearance on a 2007 ncis episode
as coffee man
ray mabus served as secretary of the
navy from may 2009 to early 2017
a tenure that included an appearance on
a 2009 episode of ncis as an agent named
ray
mark harmon not only headlines the ncis
flagship he's also an executive producer
for the show
and its spin-off ncis new orleans that
credit isn't just a perk for having been
with the franchise for so long
harman is a hands-on producer he worked
closely with fellow producer gary
glassberg to develop new orleans
participating in decisions regarding
casting shooting locations
and music selection in season three
thomas morrow was
out as ncis director and in came jenny
shepard
the character shared some history with
gibbs in that the two were once
professional partners as well as a
couple that mirrors the relationship
between the actors who portrayed shepard
and gibbs
lauren holly and mark harmon years
before ncis the two were both cast
members on the 90s cbs medical drama
chicago hope and it's that
connection that scored holly the role of
shepard
holly wrote on her official website that
harmon actually reached out when they
were having trouble casting the role and
arranged a meeting for holly with the
show's creator donald belisario
she landed the part which was initially
supposed to just be a six-episode arc
before it turned into a three-season run
after about four dozen episodes writers
killed off jenny shepard because holly
was ready to move on to other roles
paulie perette was a standout of ncis
ensemble cast since its beginnings in
2003 providing light moments as
kath powell fueled forensic scientist
abby schudo
it was both a major tv moment and a big
career move for peret when she left the
show in 2018
after more than 350 episodes you want to
help me
look just take it and go yeah you want
to help me say it you want to help me
yes i want to help you you can't stop
just after her farewell episode aired
perette tweeted out the reason why she
fled ncis
she reportedly suffered multiple
physical assaults at work
there was some animosity and negativity
stemming from an incident in 2016 when
co-star mark harmon brought his pitbull
dave to the set
according to sources that spoke with
radar online dave bit a member of the
crew with such violent
intensity that the victim had to get 16
stitches
harmon kept dave at home after that
except for the one time when
he couldn't find a dog sitter and
allowed dave to hang out in his
on-set trailer all day perette was
reportedly furious that harmon's dog was
back on the set
and started to shout when harmon tried
to explain sources say peret even
refused to shoot any scenes with harman
most huge tv shows extend their cultural
impact beyond just hundreds of episodes
offering merchandise for fans to enjoy
it's tough for an adult oriented crime
drama to sell
ancillary items but ncis had cash
registers ringing for a while
with cbs's website offering a version of
the show's burt the farting hippo
novelty toy
he's supposed to make that noise you
have a stuffed animal that farts
yeah that's cool huh burt is a cute
hippopotamus puppet
based on the one that abby sciutto kept
at her workstation
but which offered a little something
extra in that it made fart sounds
just like the one seen on around a dozen
episodes of ncis
in 2002 folk manus a company which
produces a wide line of stuffed animal
type puppets for toy stores and gift
shops introduced a hippo which ncis prop
masters used on tv with little
alteration
other than dubbing in farting sounds in
post-production
cbs eventually commissioned a more
accurate branded replica of bert from
folk manus and the toy maker added a
spiked collar and a sound box
then according to a lawsuit filed in
2014 cbs's merchandiser went around folk
manus and sought out a company in china
to make the toys so the network could
sell them at a greater profit
the puppet company wanted more than 700
thousand dollars and the suit was
settled out of court in 2016.
like any real government agency office
worth its medal the squadron ncis
headquarters features a most wanted wall
bearing the images of the worst of the
worst criminals that pose a threat to
the united states safety
and security over the years it's
featured all manner of criminals
murderers
and terrorists some of whom are created
for the show and some
real to add authenticity once the ncis
good guys eliminate them they are
removed from the wall
if they're killed the most wanted
individual gets a big red stripe across
their portrait but not
all the people on the wall are bad guys
or even real guys
for a good while the face of one of the
supposedly at-large criminals belonged
to donald belisario creator of ncis
connected properties are all the rage in
movies what with the marvel cinematic
universe and the dc extended universe
among others
but they're a thing in tv too a number
of the cw superhero shows share a common
fake reality
while ncis is also the connecting point
for a number of television shows past
and present
as it's been on the air for nearly 20
highly watched years now it's easy to
forget that ncis was a spin-off of
another less popular military drama also
created by donald belisario called jag
which aired from 1995 to 2005.
ncis itself spun off ncis los angeles
and ncis new orleans with several actors
crossing into the different shows
characters from ncis los angeles guest
starred on cbs's hawaii 5-0 which itself
crossed over with cbs's magnum pi remake
that puts all of those shows in the same
universe and you could even include
family guy
in a 2012 episode of the animated series
news anchor tom tucker becomes an actor
and lands a gig on ncis
mark harmon plays himself playing gibbs
some parts seem so tailor made to
certain actors or they portray the part
for so long that it's almost impossible
to imagine anyone else in the role
take mark harmon as gibbs for example
he's portrayed the taciturn
naval investigator for nearly two
decades and it's the role for which he's
most famous
producers originally had someone else in
mind for the role
han solo and indiana jones himself
harrison ford
according to amazon ford who was
experiencing a bit of a downturn in his
otherwise stellar movie career when ncis
was being developed in the early 2000s
was one of the producers favored options
to play gives
despite associates encouraging him to
sign on for the role he didn't have any
interest in pursuing work on the
episodic tv series
and harman got the gig with about 400
episodes of reliable and satisfying
television with high production values
and star
power filmed and ready to go ncis is an
attractive option for worldwide tv
syndicators
it's a particular draw in japan where
fox japan promoted the debut of the 11th
season
slate of episodes in january 2014 with a
rerun marathon
fox japan aired the first 10 seasons of
ncis in their entirety
and in order it took a full 10 days to
air all 234 episodes
a period which coincided with the new
year's holiday
the event also earned fox japan and ncis
a literal spot in the record books
the stunt was a shot at the guinness
world record for longest uninterrupted
transmission of a tv series
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you